caroline aigle été pilote de chasse la
première affectée au sein d'un escadron
de combat de l'armée de l'air et à
guyancourt la première des nominations
féminines de voix et d'équipements mis
en place par la commune depuis 2010 on a
la parité depuis 2010 voilà ça c'est une
vraie volonté politique depuis cette
époque là mais on a beaucoup par
attraper nous allons ouvrir deux salles
d'arts martiaux très prochainement nous
avions fait la demande avant les jeux
olympiques de tokyo
avec clarisse agbegnenou de bien vouloir
nous prêter son nom pour et elle a
accepté de ses très bien d'avoir aussi
cette diversité de noms de femmes d'une
des dernières
dénomination que nous avons fait était
celle de théroigne de méricourt sur sur
le my des saules vendredi 17 septembre
guyancourt a signé la charte européenne
d'égalité hommes-femmes
la commune a deux ans pour respecter ses
engagements divers comme une
sensibilisation auprès des jeunes
l'impact sur la carrière d'agent public
mais aussi pour la vie locale
d'aiguillon courtois je crois très
fortement par exemple dans la
scolarisation des enfants de moins de 3
ans pour plein de raisons pour leur sang
pour leur sociabilisation pour leur
scolarité bien évidemment mais aussi
mais aussi parce que c'est un levier
puissant pour permettre notamment à des
femmes de reprendre une activité
professionnelle
on souhaite également maintenir ce
nombre de places en crèche important
pour une ville de notre strates et ça
aussi ce sont des leviers pour cent
guyancourt organise chaque année le
temps des femmes un mois d'animations
d'activité d'exposition la commune
espère donner rendez vous d'ici deux ans
pour évaluer les résultats